der verfall ist bestürzend dass aus
meiner sicht ganz klar ein verbrechen
also gegen die menschheit das ist nicht
hinzunehmen dass putin also hier im
mitverantwortlich ist das halte ich für
gegeben dann entweder werden die nerven
gehst du nicht ausreichend geschützt
oder sie werden von dem eingesetzt one
way or other wie man so sagt also ist
das tatsächlich hier russland anzulasten
und von daher belastet das natürlich das
verhältnis zwischen deutschland und
russland zu recht schwer
also zunächst einmal freut es mich dass
ich gesundheitlich wieder besser geht
aber diese äußerungen da befinden wir
uns jetzt schon auf stammtischniveau
ich finde auch herr navalny sollte da
seine worte wohl ab mit mir persönlich
fehlt der letzte schlüssige beweis der
nachweis wirklich gerichtsfeste nachweis
dass putin persönlich diesen angriff
hätte angeordnete ich meine mittlerweile
ist ja sehr einfach man muss nur
irgendwie jemanden auf der welt
vergiften mit neuen job um putin war es
das ist gerade sowie werden mörder eine
visitenkarte am tatort hinterlässt für
so dumm
das sage ich jetzt auch mal ganz offen
ist meine persönliche meinung halte ich
an putin nicht also ich fand die
einlassung von gerhard schröder zum
fallen dabei auch schwierig muss ganz
ehrlich sagen dass das auch eines
altkanzlers nicht würdig war
ob die zahlungen fließen oder nicht dazu
möchte ich mich nicht äußern ich habe
dazu keine kenntnisse kann das auch
ehrlich gesagt so weit nicht glauben
aber trotzdem die rolle von gerhard
schröder schon zweifelhaft aber
insgesamt ist dieser vorfall natürlich
zu verurteilen
insgesamt sind ist das ja nur ein fall
von vielen die in der russischen mit der
russischen föderation in zusammenhang
gebracht werden gebraucht eine
internationale antwort
und hier ist die bundesregierung ja auch
im gespräch mit vielen anderen beim
navalny spricht dann hört jetzt die
ganze welt hin
natürlich weil er vergiftet wurde in
russland aber auch weil er der
prominenteste oppositionelle ist und
auch der prominenteste investigativ
ermittler in russland niemand hat so
viel korruption auf höchster staatsebene
in russland aufgedeckt wie navalny und
navalny hat gestern sehr klar über
schröder gesprochen und hat gesagt
er weiß dass schröder in seiner eigenen
partei bei der spd mittlerweile auch
kritisch gesehen wird das haben wir
gerade von herrn karl lauterbach gehört
man kann aber auch sehen an den
äußerungen von florian post der zweite
abgeordnete der gesprochen hat das immer
noch ein völlig bizarres russland
verständnis vorherrscht er hat gesagt
herr post hat gesagt dass er putin nicht
für so dumm hält dass er seine
visitenkarte spricht dass novacek gift
einfach bei den morden hinterlässt ich
halte putin ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
für dumm
ich glaube das problem liegt eher bei
westlichen abgeordneten die so
gutgläubig sind und tatsächlich sich
einfach weigern die realität
anzuerkennen wer konnte denn navalny in
russland vergiften mit einem russischen
militärischen nerven kampfstoff ja und
schauen wir uns doch einfach mal die
ermittlungen an es gibt keine ermittlung
in russland das einer wollen die selbst
auch gesagt heute hat außenminister
lavrov erst vor wenigen minuten gesagt
dass der nachweis dass new york
eingesetzt wurde ja nicht von der
berliner charité erbracht wurde sondern
vom bundeswehr labor und dem könne man
ja natürlich nicht trauen man wissen
nicht welches spiel deutschland da
spiele ja also das macht sehr klar wie
die spd da steht da tut es ehrlich
gesagt gut deutliche worte zu hören wie
vom csu abgeordneten florian hahn der
sich klar für ermittlungen gegen
russland ausgesprochen hat in deinen
augen müsste die spd sich klarer ab
trend sowohl russland als auch zu
gerhard schröder und seiner rolle die er
jetzt spielt ja so die spd fährt seit
vielen jahren einen etwas unklaren
russland kurs hat viele kreml freunde
bei sich in der partei das soll die spd
machen wie sie will
der fall schröder wird natürlich einfach
peinlich für die spd also es gibt
wirklich keinen völkerrechts bruch den
russland begeht kein angriffskrieg den
putin veranstaltet den herr schröder
nicht sofort versucht schönzureden
und jetzt das das es wirklich einfach
peinlich das merkt auch die spd-spitze
dass das alexej nawalny in russland
vergiftet wird auf druck der
bundesregierung nach deutschland auch
geflogen wird auch die so viel mitleid
so viel sympathie von der deutschen
bevölkerung bekommt und dann kommt herr
schröder um die ecke und zweifelt alle
fakten an sagt es gebe gar keine es sei
alles im wesentlich eine spekulation
versucht wieder den kreml da aus der
schusslinie zu bringen so was kann sich
die ehemalige volkspartei spd eigentlich
nicht leisten
vielen dank für die piazza für diese
einschätzung
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren